Hi everybody.
Welcome to our talk the Agentic AI
engineer. I'm Bene.
CEO and co-founder of Mutagent and I'm
here with my colleague.
>> Hi, I'm Burak. I'm the CTO of Mutagent
and today we're basically going to talk
about loops and how the Agentic AI
engineer works.
>> So,
as you all are aware of now, loops is
the hot topic how you build software
in an Agentic loop. And we apply the
same loop to the building of AI agents.
And as you all aware, there is uh
two concepts here. One is
the offline loop where while you build,
you iterate um on your agent, you test
it, you evaluate it, you improve it, and
you go on. And then you have a second
loop which is we call the online loop
where once the agent is deployed to
production, you monitor its traces, you
diagnose it, and then you feed it back
into your optimization loop uh yeah, to
iterate and have multiple versions of
your agents.
Yeah, up to until now um what we did
was uh
just doing this loop manually. It's
quite slow.
Um the life cycle is basically
um you have an issue, um you want to
change something to your agent. Um yeah,
you implement the change. Um [snorts]
you maybe vibe implement the change if
you use coding agents for it.
Um yeah, you generate some samples for
this new feature or issue to test it.
Um yeah, then you look at the result,
you look through the traces, how does
the outcome look like.
Then you maybe ship it, you do AB
testing, and all your feedback is kind
of manually, it takes very long. Um
yeah, and uh
the the bottleneck basically becomes the
human review and the human
yeah, building time. And yeah, that you
can't scale especially if in your
organization you're not planning to roll
out
hundreds of agents etc.
Yeah, and uh
yeah, this is why
we think the Agentic AI engineer is the
natural next step to build agents.
And I'll have Burak deep dive into how
we improve timing and the road to
production reliability with the Agentic
AI engineer.
>> Uh so, yeah, the key thing here is
basically once you reach a certain
number of agents or AI-based features,
the human performing this loop again
cannot really scale in enough time. So,
this is why doing this agentically is
the key to increasing the throughput
because then you can fit many more
cycles into the same time window.
And now how that loop works is
basically we have a few stages. So, this
is when you are starting from scratch
like the current software development
practices, you first create a spec for
your agent
or your skill in this case. And here you
need to define all the responsibilities
and the functions that agents needs to
handle, the
decisions that it has to make on certain
conditions.
And here again, this is only the
definition stage.
Once you defined your agent's
requirements, then you can finally go on
to the build. And build is where you
then realize that spec in a specific
harness or uh
agent framework or in these days you
could even build it as a cloud code or a
codex agent.
Then comes the next step. This is where
you define clear evaluations to evaluate
your agent's performance because these
are the key
metrics then where you can say, "Hey, my
agent is functional or not." Uh
can think of essentially the equivalent
to unit tests for coding. This is how
you verify your agent works.
Then after evaluation, if everything
looks fine, you usually have the ship
basically where you deploy this agent to
production.
Uh
again, this can be a code update. This
can be a direct update on a any agent
platform or again your local harness
agents.
Then comes the online part. This is
where then the agent is continuously
monitored for issues and based on
certain trigger conditions, then you can
start automatic diagnostics. Again, this
can be based on the volume of traces
that your agent generates or, you know,
weekly or daily jobs.
Uh then we go into diagnosis stage. This
is where you collect all the failures
for your agents and do structured root
cause analysis to then understand where
the failures are coming from.
Once you understand and categorize the
failures, then you can finally go on to
the optimization stage. This is where
then you create,
let's say, very specific changes or
mutations for your agents and to deal
with the found failure modes.
And then the whole cycle repeats again.
You evaluate and if everything looks
good, then you can deploy again.
Now, we will maybe do a deep dive on
each stage, what that entails.
Then
>> So,
before we continue, Burak,
um we have two passes here.
Like one is the cold start path, and one
is basically existing features. Um
should we dive deeper for like a half a
minute on what differences here, what we
see, and why this is important.
Yeah.
>> Yeah, so today, if you again sit down to
build an agent, there are,
you know, two options. Either you
already have an agent, it's built, it's
already running somewhere
with
um, you know, certain accuracy.
However,
the other option is again you are
creating from scratch. So, when you
create from scratch, obviously you
design with the spec and the
conceptualization stage.
If you have an existing feature, the
most likely again the agent is there,
but then you are optimizing over
something that already exists.
>> Okay, cool.
And [snorts]
Yeah, let's dive deeper into each phase.
I mean, you just mentioned the specking
of new building agents, so this seems to
be an important artifact, so let's dive
into it.
>> Right.
So, with the spec-driven development,
also prevalent for building software
artifacts these days, or any kind of
coding agent workflows,
basically the goal is to capture the
requirements for the agent, and
especially the success criteria.
The reason being, apart from coding
agents, the agents in other domains
they handle specific processes and this
differs from company to company, so it's
very
specialized to the environment where the
agent is in.
And then the key point here is to
clearly define which context
requirements that the agent has, again
which integrations and tools it then
needs to have.
What are the jobs to be done or the
responsibilities that the agent will
handle and what it will not.
And then finally again the constraints
and in general the boundaries for the
agent.
>> Okay.
>> Now once we can define a clear spec as I
said it becomes like a blueprint for any
future development which then the
implementation is held against.
>> Okay. And let's dive into how we would
then build an agent from the spec,
right?
>> Right.
So basically then the spec tells your
coding agent
what to build and then here the target
platform choice is entirely yours.
Cuz as I mentioned
agent space is very changing very
rapidly these days.
So the framework you are using today,
you might want to change, you know, in a
year or so.
So essentially because of that spec is
isolated from the implementation
details. So once you decide to
you can pick any target.
Here then your coding agent of your
choice will take that spec and give you
a, you know, initial version of that
agent, which is then basically
customized to run on any platform that
you see fit.
>> Why would I want to change the platform
in a year down the line? So, what what
what did we learn out of experience
here?
Um
>> Uh again
building agents for the last 3 years,
sometimes the agent framework or the
harness does not always have the
capabilities. So,
occasionally you hit
um like a bottleneck or a roadblock, and
then you have to rely on the underlying
framework to kind of get rid of that,
and this can sometimes take a while.
The key here is to be flexible because
yeah, essentially again,
it you want to pick the best harness or
the framework that can, you know,
fulfill your requirements.
>> Mhm.
I mean, we've all seen it in the in the
last months,
we how new harnesses shipped and
yeah, how everything went from like a
agents building code towards yeah,
defined as like a agent loop run time.
I mean, we've seen Hermes coming up,
deep agents, and all of these
frameworks, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, let's continue.
What happens after build?
>> Now,
after you build
for agents,
you essentially go into the eval-driven
development loop, which I would call.
And this is kind of equivalent to
test-driven development for building
software with agents because then the
agents needs
uh
termination condition, right? So, when
is an AI feature or an agent is good
enough?
So, here again there are two ways to
kind of create your eval suite, which is
composed of the evals like the metrics
and the criteria you evaluate.
And the data sets themselves, which
usually contain the cases you have to
satisfy.
Now, in the beginning, the original
option is that you
can sit with your domain experts
and then try to write down
eval metrics and criteria that would
cover the feature or the agent you want
to build, but most teams working on that
will already know that this is a bit
difficult as in you cannot pre-guess
the entire evaluation suite from the
beginning.
And secondly, you can always start with
historical data or synthesized data from
a known
you know, sample of the data that you
would like agent to be tested on.
But essentially, the real and the
complete eval suite is a product of
discovery. What that means is
over time, from user feedback, from
production failures, you collect the
metrics and criteria plus the additional
data set cases,
uh which is often representative for
edge cases or you know, hard cases that
the agent needs to deal with.
And with that, then you finally have an
evaluation suit where you can run the
agent against an exactly know where it
fails.
>> Okay, before we continue,
why does the Agentic AI engineer help us
here so much? So, um obviously we're
talking about the evaluator agent. So,
why is it so why is it so good to use
this kind of concept or thought process
in the building?
>> Well, I mean one issue is again, imagine
you have a data set item of
200. Here, without automated evals,
running this and evaluating by like
human eyes takes quite a while.
Um
you would have to again scroll through
an observability dashboard and logs
and
this in turn increases your loop time
per eval state. So, as soon as you have
a lot of features that you need to
evaluate and experiment on, then it
suddenly becomes impossible to, you
know, do this quickly or in parallel.
Then the human essentially becomes the
bottleneck.
>> Okay. So, we just have an agent do this
work in sifting through traces.
>> Yes, as the current era says a bit, you
know,
um you design loops for your agent so
then they can autonomously work as many
of these things in the background. Uh
and then your job becomes designing
these loops with a clear eval or
termination gate.
>> Okay. Understood. So,
let's look at the how good eval
uh supposed to be constructed and what
it kind of evaluates.
>> Right. So, in the context of agents
in general,
the mainly the trajectory is important
because
agents receive input or let's say intent
or tasks and then they have a specific
system prompt or like a decision tree
that they
kind of operate over.
And when doing agent evaluations, again
in general, we check, "Hey,
was the context complete?" As in, did
the agent have all the required context
to perform the task end to end?
Then this includes also chain checking
every, you know, tool output in the
trajectory because every
wrong tool output in
session can in the end lead to our wrong
output as the final output.
And
apart from that, again, there are
different things you can evaluate on.
So, these days also the harness that the
agent is operating on has quite drastic
effects on the agent behavior.
And this is again another vector of
optimization.
But in the end, when you evaluate an
agent, you would like to evaluate all of
these things and not something in just
isolation.
>> Mhm.
>> Right.
And
in general, here, what makes an eval
useful? So, you can always have
you know, metrics or evals that are
working in a LLM as a judge fashion and
give you some score, but
here, in order to make an eval, you
know, useful, it has to provide
actionable feedback.
Uh, as in
when you use score-based evals, unless
your rubric is very well defined, then
this does not exactly tell you what to
fix.
Uh, in such cases, using uh, binary type
of evals or criteria,
is preferred because there you have a
kind of a call to action. If an eval or
a criteria fails, then you know exactly
what happened and how to kind of deal
with that problem.
Then, uh, another point is your LLM as a
judge
solution should be calibrated so that
you don't have the, uh, scoring noise
between judges because
since LLM
LLMs are undeterministic, what you will
mostly encounter is the same judge can,
uh, evaluate a problem different ways on
each run.
And then here, you have to make sure
your LLM as a judge solution deals with
this variance problem. Otherwise, it's
hard to
run experiments and conclusively say,
"Hey, my initial or my improved version
is better than my initial version of my
agent."
>> Mhm.
>> Right.
Uh, after then evaluation,
basically, we go live and this is where
then, uh,
collecting, let's say, learned failures,
failure
or primary signals
from the execution takes place.
Um here the idea is again when an agent
encounters a problem over time, there
will most likely be multiple occurrences
of these. So, it starts by identifying
what failure mode
uh
that the agent has encountered
and then grouping essentially these
failure modes by the root causes and
where they originate from. Again, this
could be a section in the agent prompt.
This could be
missing tools or, let's say,
malfunctioning tools.
But, after your diagnostics results are
categorized, then you can finally
generate new evaluations. First, to
detect these problems.
And then, second, you can generate
improvements and remedies based on these
problems.
And yeah, with that, over time, you have
um
build-up of these learned failure modes.
So, then every agent over time
uh gathers
these historical data that it can always
check against. When you
uh start diagnosing, there's a bit of a
upfront cost in the beginning because
you often need to deep read the LLM
traces to find out what's going on.
Over time, you can collect
code-checkable indicators per failure
mode.
What that means is there are maybe
specific pieces of content or there's a
specific tool called sequence
where you know that the agent will
encounter an issue and then this later
on helps you to diagnose problems in
your traces without actually having to
read through all your traces.
Now, why is that a problem? Because if
you have
let's say millions of agent traces
and to read all of these
uh it actually costs more than the
execution itself. So, it's not the most
efficient way of diagnosing
the problems. Uh what you want to aim
for is again try to
uh pick a representative sample
from your um whole traces
by you know
intelligent segmentation strategies and
using again as I said the learned
indicators.
>> Okay, cool.
>> And
then with that you can finally start
building the autonomous optimization
loop because
here then given that you have a eval
suit, you can you know
vary your feature again update certain
or even run auto research style
experiments
to see that whether you can reach the
desired or the target scores for your
evals. As long as you can reach that
then it's automatically shipped to
production.
Then
from production you have your outer
loop.
Again, every issue that's found then on
diagnostics gives you a
improvement or a remedy which then you
can optimize on and then as long as the
eval suite is green then this again gets
deployed to production.
>> Let's continue now with the whole life
cycle.
Um
yeah, as we learned now the details of
each everything starts with a spec.
Um you define and design it. Uh you
build your agent and all of this can be
done obviously agentic. So you define
agents that do this work.
And then they all together become
uh the agentic AI engineer. Um you go
through the offline loop where once you
build your evaluation system
uh
yeah, you evaluate, you optimize, you
test, you improve your accuracy on your
test data set.
Once you feel ready, you deploy it to
production.
And that's when the online loop starts.
Here you get real feedback from users.
Um
yeah, uh you review the test cases, you
continuously monitor them, you look at
your live traces, you diagnose them as
we learned before with the diagnose
agent you can do root cause analysis,
you can cluster your failure modes. Uh
you'll derive new eval criteria from it.
They become part of the spec.
Uh they become part of the agent. So
they they continuously
grow with you while you use your agent
in production.
And uh yeah, this becomes the online
loop. And the more use cases you
collect, the more is production data you
see, the better your agent becomes and
the better scoring your agent becomes.
And this all together now
um becomes one end-to-end loop that you
can run agentic. And uh yeah, from here
on uh
yeah, you can now see
the combination to software-driven
development with coding agents. You can
transport this concepts also for AI
engineering and building AI agents.
And uh now, as we at Mutagen work on
this,
we're going to show you now how this
looks like as a product.
Um
This is kind of how it looks like. Um
for now, everything runs in your
environment. And we it as cloud and
local, um
we'll offer a managed service down the
line.
Um so, it's a set of
agents. We have two in research preview.
The ones we talked deep about this in
our talk.
First one is the evaluator agent that
helps you build
an eval set, a good data set, because
this is the core of the optimization,
the eval driven development loop.
The second one we have is the diagnose
the diagnostics agent.
It does you It helps you diagnose your
traces you already have in productions,
because we learned from our users that
reading through these traces took them a
lot of time, and having kind of they can
just spin off from their coding
environment to analyze the traces
is
very helpful to them.
And as you can see here,
um both of these agents um are connected
through an orchestrator, which runs in
your coding environment. And what you
need basically is connectors to sources
where you basically have all your
traces, where you get your incidents
from. This could also be like your
ticketing system,
um Slack where people report failures of
your agents. Then you connect them. And
then, obviously, as we mentioned before,
there's different target platforms.
Um this could be come a PR that
automatically gets raised in GitHub. Um
this could be just the adjustment of
your agents in uh
in MD files. Uh yeah, different
frameworks we target. And or being
deployed to managed services. Um yeah,
kind of this is how our platform works.
We spin up different agents. They are
connected to an orchestra and I guess
Burak, let's show uh our first agent in
research preview to the audience.
>> Uh in practice, as I said, you have um
orchestrator which kind of handles the
dispatch for all the other sub agents or
stages we have.
And
then you can use it in any coding
harness or agent you want. In this case,
I'm using code code.
But then what it will do is when you
first boot up, it will show you kind of
like a dashboard of which stages you
have and also kind of the existing
things in uh
let's say your code base, your agents,
and the prior configurations.
Now here I have some start commands.
These are basically, let's say, trigger
commands for the workflows or specific
stages. And if I type diagnose here,
this will basically start the diagnostic
stage for the root cause analysis.
And here again, you can point the
diagnostics into a specific scope. This
can be an agent. This can be a skill as
well. So you could basically diagnose
all invocations of a particular skill.
Here
uh when you start the diagnostics, it
will
uh retrieve traces from your configured
source platform. In this case, again, it
can be something like LangFuse. It can
be your local cloud transcripts or
another
you know, like a JSON L format that's
like exported from one of the
observability platforms.
Now,
the diagnostics run itself takes quite a
while to finish, so I will show you
instead a pre-generated
kind of version of what it does and how
that looks like in the end.
Okay, so what do we see here now?
So, basically, once you run the
diagnostics agent, as I said, on your
agents, you will get a
um, generated HTML artifact,
which basically shows
you, you know, the details of your
agent, which tools you have.
Uh,
then in general, if you
if you have code access, it will also
tell you which harness or the framework
that the agent is using.
And then here, in general, it will
basically go through your traces and
then select primary signals, or let's
say failure modes,
depending on how frequent they occur in
the trace samples.
Now, as I said, most of the time you
don't want to read all of your traces
because this is not cost-efficient. So,
there the
diagnostics use like a
a multi-tier
filtering or segmentation to kind of
pick a representative sample, so
uh,
originally, a few, you know, pieces of
the traces, or let's say,
portion will be read by the LLM to see
that if there any detectable obvious
problems.
And based on that, then
diagnostics can decide or to focus on a
particular failure mode or a signal.
Uh the other option is then
trigger the diagnostics, you can also
specify an issue that you have seen
yourself or issue that you're looking
for.
This could be something that the users
reported.
Uh in this case, it's again more of a
guided search, meaning
hey, if you tell the diagnostics agent
you have a particular problem you're
interested in, then it will try to find
all incidents or occurrences regarding
the same problem.
>> Okay.
And what do we see here in uh
in
yeah, in full here?
>> Uh
so, this is in general the overview,
which tells you again which
issues kind of were detected and kind of
shows you like the frequency
giving the given time frame. Then for
each tab, you will have a failure mode
and kind of like an explanation of the
problem.
And then here,
you can kind of see where that problem
comes from or why it happens.
The agent will provide kind of like
um
uh recursive why chain, let's say, to
then tell you, "Hey,
this is where the issue is originating
from."
Now, in addition, it will offer you kind
of remedies or fixes to deal with that.
And then here, you will see an
assumptions block.
Uh here, this is important because uh
when you are reading traces, sometimes
you don't always have access to the
code, so this helps us detect
uh,
LLM or let's say the diagnostics agent
makes certain assumptions that are also
not correct and we can see and correct
them here.
Uh,
but in the end you will be presented by
certain corrections or remedies, which
then kind of can fix your problem. You
can, you know, pick either the
recommended or, you know, as many as you
need as it's multi-choice.
And once you basically go through all
your problems,
uh,
at the end you kind of get to a
decisions page and here again for those
using, you know,
text-to-speech or speech-to-text AI
features like Whisper flow, there's
always a
general feedback box so that you can
always talk into your mic.
And finally, when you are happy with all
the decisions, you get a markdown,
let's say, um,
task definition for your coding agent.
So, all the fixes or the remedies can
then be directly applied to once you go
back to your terminal and to your coding
agent.
>> Thanks for the demo, Burak.
So,
last words
on our product.
Yeah, so, uh,
thanks for listening into our talk.
Um, yeah, I hope we could show you some,
uh, good insights on how we
envision the future of agent building
with the Agent AI engineer.
Um yeah, stop uh, the debugging.
Um
have agents do the tedious work and
reach out to us if you have further
questions.
And
yeah, have a great conference.